" La France est en guerre.
Les actes commis vendredi soir à Paris
et près du Stade de France
sont des actes de guerre. "
Le congrès, normalement, on le réunit
quand on veut réviser la constitution, etc.
C’est une réponse politique
à cette nuit d’horreur.
On est le lundi 16 novembre
donc on se réveille
après ce week-end d’horreur.
" Ce sont les attentats les plus meurtriers
de l'histoire de France.
Des hommes tirent à
l'arme lourde sur les passants.
Des scènes de guerre
en plein coeur de la capitale.
Pour la première fois en France,
il s'agit d'attaques kamikazes. "
Et effectivement, dès le lundi,
le premier acte politique de la semaine
c'est de réunir les députés
et les sénateurs en congrès.
Il y a une ambiance qui est
évidemment très grave,
très lourde et très digne.
Il y a un très long
couloir à parcourir
je crois que c'est
une trentaine de secondes
ce qui est énorme en fait
quand on voit l'homme d'État, seul, marcher.
Il n'y a aucun bruit.
" Monsieur le président de la République ! "
C'est vraiment les représentants
de la Nation qui sont tous là
et les partis politiques
n'existent plus entre guillemets.
C'est la France, par ses représentants,
qui est réunie au Congrès de Versailles.
" Vous êtes les représentants
d'un peuple libre
qui est invincible quand
il est uni et rassemblé.
C'est notre bien
le plus précieux.
Et nous devons éviter
surenchères et dérives.
Nous devons pouvoir déchoir
de sa nationalité française
un individu condamné pour
une atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux
de la Nation ou
un acte terroriste
même s'il est né français. "
Il y avait une volonté
d’une réponse politique très ferme
et effectivement la déchéance
de nationalité est présentée
comme une mesure symbolique
et très forte contre le terrorisme.
Mais beaucoup à gauche
ne vont absolument pas
se retrouver dans cette mesure
et la gauche va se diviser
entièrement et vraiment
sur cette question
de la déchéance de nationalité.
" Le terrorisme ne détruira
pas la République,
car c’est la République
qui le détruira.
Vive la République
et vive la France ! "
Il y avait eu
une Marseillaise spontanée
après les attentats de
Charlie Hebdo et de l'Hyper Cacher.
Il s'est passé la même chose
au Congrès, à Versailles.
Le Congrès de Versailles,
c'est le moment où LCP, je pense,
se dit qu'elle vit un moment
qui sera écrit dans les livres d'Histoire.